So, it's my pleasure today,
uh to uh welcome Quan Pham
uh for our guest lecture. Uh he
co-founded Physical Intelligence uh and
focuses on large-scale pre-training
uh for cross-embodiment uh robot models.
He obtained his PhD at uh USC
>> [clears throat]
>> uh UCSD, sorry.
Uh during which he was advised by uh
Henry Christensen and Howie Su. And
before co-founding uh Physical
Intelligence, Quan worked at Google
DeepMind uh where he uh started and
co-led uh RTX and Open X Embodiment
project. Uh and with this, uh please
give him a uh warm applause.
Go ahead, Quan.
>> Sounds good. Yeah, I can actually see
the Zoom link and I'm not going to try
to make it show up. So, you know, if you
have anything uh feel free to interrupt
me. So, I'll keep today really informal,
um just to share what our recent
progress is. And I think my goal today
is really to interact with uh Roy
community at ETH. So, if you have any
questions, save them for the end.
Um so, PILE-7, um this is a work that we
released recently. And
I would say that one of the main
innovation in this work is to get a
single model that can perform many tasks
and perform many tasks at an extremely
high level of performance. Um
why is this important and why is this
hard? Um so, first, why is this
important? Um previously, when you
wanted to get really high performance
for any particular task in end-to-end
learning, normally what you do is you
take a pre-trained model that are
somewhat reasonable in performance, and
not great, and then you post-train that
model um to that specific task.
And the reason why getting a single
model that can perform many tasks at
high level performance is important is
that it's much more scalable, right? You
don't have You don't have to You don't
need to worry about which model
checkpoint, what is hyper parameter
during test time I use for a particular
task.
Um
the the fewer model that you have to
manage, the easier it is
uh
for you to scale. And it's hard because
um it is not obvious how to do it. It's
a really open research question. And
Pilot 7 uh by no means solved this
question of how do we get the best
model that can perform many tasks, uh
but I think it's a meaningful uh
improvement.
And so, I think we're in the age of
scaling for robotics. Um and when people
talk about scaling, usually there are
two main axes. There's data and there's
model. And
one challenge is that it's it's not
obvious what do you scale, and then how
do you scale it? Uh for example, if you
take all of the data um
that you might have in robotics and you
train the model on it, most likely it
won't be a great model. It won't be as
good as a specialist model that has been
really heavily tuned and optimized for a
particular scenario. And
you know, if you [clears throat] look at
face value, what that means is uh more
data doesn't equal uh uh more
uh performing model.
So, um
the majority of the rest of the talk
will focus on
uh how Pilot 7 was able to
produce a single checkpoint that can
match specialist performance.
So, if you look at the top right of this
um slide here,
what this is showing is a figure from
one of our previous work called RL
token.
Um X axis is the episode length of
episodes in during evaluation and Y axis
are um success rates.
Um
what this is illustrating is that the
green are demonstrating the speed of a
human teleoperator controlling the
robot. Um
the
slightly pink
the base policy um is illustrating the
speed of a policy trained on the
teleoperation data, which is actually
slower than the speed of the human
teleoperator, um which is kind of
interesting, right? Because you would
expect that
good imitation learned policy will at
least reproduce the speed that you see
in um your training data.
And then the yellow um which RL token
wanted to show was that if you perform
online reinforcement learning, you can
get the speed to be superhuman in this
case, um where you can see that the
yellow plots are to the left of the
green plots.
Um so one original question that you can
ask here is first, how is it possible
that um
you have a data set, you take a policy,
you train on that data set, and the
policy is actually slower than the data
set? And how is it that um
how do you get a generalist policy that
have the same speed as the specialist
that were trained using reinforcement
learning?
So here comes PIO 7. PIO 7 in terms of
the architecture of the actual um action
drive generation component of the system
has not changed significantly from our
prior work. Um it's very similar to PIO
6, uh very similar to PIO 5. We use a
language model and a pre-trained vision
encoder to and then we kind of graph an
action expert onto it to
teach the model on how to speak robot's
language, if you will.
So, the model takes in a prompt, for
example, clean the kitchen.
Um it might also additionally take in a
subtask from which indicates a
subtask that if you do it and if you
finish, you know, the rest of the
subtask, you will finish the task
instruction.
Um and additionally, there are metadata
that indicates the speed and the quality
of the episode that you're training on.
One other innovation in Pilot 7 is the
goal condition
capability of the model that leads to a
much better generalization that I'll
also touch on later.
Oh, oops. I can't go back to the Ah,
here we are. Um and so, the what I just
talked about are the action generation
component of the system. There is also a
high-level component and the way to
think about the high-level component is
it's not like a planner. You know, it is
the the the high-level which are
indicated either by the human or the
high-level policy or the world model um
here
are not capable of generating low-level
actions themselves, but they are capable
of generating plans for
um the low-level to
figure out what actions to take to
execute on those plans.
So,
to show you the kind of um
tasks that the Pilot 7 model are capable
of and
these are tasks that stress test very
different axes.
Um there is laundry folding um which has
to deal with infinite state space.
There is really precise task of screwing
um a tiny screw into a robot arm. On the
right, there's a task of building a box
that require um really
precise two-hand coordination. And
there's a long-horizon task of taking
out the trash on the bottom. Um and the
noteworthy thing here is that all of
this video and all of this task were
performed by a single checkpoint um from
the PIO 7 pre-training run.
These are the kind of figure that I
won't go into the detail um
but the main takeaway here is first,
let's look at the um
different policy that are presented
here. So, there are
there is PIO 7 uh which is the
pre-trained model and there is
what we call RL specialist and SFT
specialist. And to abstract away detail
of what you think about this specialist
is that these were policies that were
specifically tuned to get high
performance on specific tasks. Um
and you know, if you glance at the
slide, you can
kind of see that the yellow, which is
PIO 7, is either the same or actually
better than the specialist.
Um which is the part that I was trying
to get across, which is um
I think this is the first time where at
least for PIO it's possible for us to
get a single checkpoint that perform as
well as policies that are specifically
tuned for different tasks. Now, the even
more interesting bit here is that in
some of these plots, you see that the
yellow is actually better
than the specialist. Um which is
interesting, right? Which is this is
saying that
when you have a specialist that have
been specifically tuned for
a particular scenario
um that are already very high
performing. Now, you if you can get a
generalist to also perform well in those
scenario, the generalist can actually
perform better. And now, why is that the
case? Um that is the case because in
large-scale um
robotic evaluation, really every
evaluation is a generalization
evaluation. Um where you try to have
control experiments and you try to fix
the scene as much as possible, but
there's al-
always going to be some factor that
change. And because you have a
generalist, um it's going to be
generally more robust to
subtle change in the environment, um and
therefore can actually outperform the
specialist. And we we really try our
best to make it a apple-to-apple
comparison here in terms of data that
different model are allowed to see.
Now, one of the interesting plot from
the PILE 7 paper is this plot on the
left here. Um
the x-axis is the percentage of data
used in training,
>> [clears throat]
>> where as you
go towards the left of the x-axis, you
use fewer data. Um but the data are
higher quality. And if you go to the
right ax- to the right of the x-axis,
you use more data, but the data are
lower quality. Um so, if when when you
go across
the x-axis to the right,
um you are increasing the volume of data
that you train on by adding lower
quality data.
>> [clears throat]
>> And
there are two um policies that are being
compared. There is PILE 7 without
metadata, and we can see here that
increasing
the data volume actually leads to
decrease performance when you go from
80% to 100%. Uh when you add the really
low quality data into training,
um
which is a
kind of experimental evidence that um
illustrate the point that I made at the
beginning, which is that more data is
not necessarily better.
Um now, the interesting The other
interesting bit here is that
the second policy that I'm being shown,
PyTorch 7 with metadata, there is a huge
jump in performance going from 80% to
100%. Um
and this is by adding lower quality
data. Um and so this is showing a plot
where
by
representing information to your policy
properly,
um you can actually benefit from lower
quality data and benefit in a pretty
dramatic way.
Um now, in addition to all of the thing
that I just mentioned about
high-performing policies, um one other
really interesting result from PyTorch 7
is cross-environment transfer. Now, how
do we categorize cross-environment
transfer here? Let's say you have um
these two robot arms here, you collected
data for folding a shirt, and this is
the task that's hard. This is a task
that can require up to like hundreds and
hundreds of hours of data
because it's a pretty precise
manipulation task that also have to deal
with
um
with a very large observation space.
Um
now, with PyTorch 7, it's possible for
you to take the policy checkpoint that
was trained on only shirt folding data
from the robot on the left, and now run
it on the robot on the right here, which
is
um
a station of two UR5, and have the
station of the two URF performing shirt
folding as well. And
we've never
included any shirt folding data at all
um from the biome URF station. So, this
is
generalization to an unseen task on
a
unseen robot and task combination.
Um and one thing that's interesting to
me about this result is that this is not
a simple task. Um this is a very
difficult task and we were very
surprised um
how how well the policy works
in this case.
Um this part I haven't touched on the
high-level planning aspect of PIO 7. Um
what these videos are showing is that if
you have
a human that's coaching the robot by
giving
language instruction, you can actually
get the system to perform tasks that
you haven't collected data in before.
And also on completely unseen
environment and seen objects. Like this
is the task where
the human is trying to coach the robot
the FRIA sweet potato and the FRIA
uh are just not in the training data um
at all.
Let me skip this slide.
Um so
at Pi uh we believe that robotic is very
far from being solved and we really want
to help propel the community forward
whenever we can. Um and part of that
effort is to
create the infrastructure for everyone
across the world to experiment with
robotics.
Um so we open sourced Pi 0 and Pi 0.5
and
people are always very surprised when
they ask me the question, is there any
difference between the Pi 0 and Pi 05
model that is open source and the model
that researcher uses at Pi? Um and
actually there is no difference. Um
the checkpoint that we open source for
Pi 0 and Pi 05 are also the checkpoint
that researcher at Pi uses for their
daily work.
Um one other thing that I wanted to
show, which is in this slide, is this
uh blog post that we did called the
physical intelligence layer. Uh I'm
showing the blog post here with the URL
so that you can look it up yourself um
later on as well. Um
The The The reason why this blog post is
interesting is you can ask the question
um
if Pi can build a really great uh
robotic model and when Pi does so, how
does Pi externalize it? Um that is to
say, how does Pi make that intelligence
available for the rest of the world to
use?
Um and
as part of understand as part of an
exercise to understand how Pi make that
model available for the rest of the
world to use, we work very closely with
robotic company that want to deploy
robots today to see if the model and the
system that we're building and they're
also building are good enough for real
task today.
>> [clears throat]
>> And the first video that
Excuse Excuse me. The first video that
you see when you go to this blog post is
a video of a robot from Weave Robotics
that are folding laundry in
um a real laundromat in the mission, uh
which is
where in San Francisco that uh Pi and
Weave are in. Um and this is
interesting. One reason is because they
are completely unseen clothing items and
this is performing
laundry folding for a real customer
order.
Uh in the blog post um there are also
example of various scenario where the
robot has to be somewhat intelligent to
recover from either error or to be able
to fold a really complex item of
clothing. For example, these jeans with
really long um
pants.
Um it's pretty hard to fold because the
two legs of the pant would get tangled
together.
So, that's one example.
The other example that the blog post
show um is this example of a robot
packaging
a task. Now, what the task here is um
well, I'm not sure how it works in uh
where you guys are, but in the US if you
order an item from Amazon, it sometimes
come in this small soft pouch that the
package uh package in. And the task here
is that there is a
uh
tray containing, you know, various kind
of items and the robot has to supposed
to pick them and put it through this
really small gap here uh into the
packaging machine. And then when the
package is sealed, the robot is supposed
to pick up the package and put it over
here to be ready to be shipped out. Um
and this task is hard because one of the
deformable items, like there are can be
many different kind of items that the
robot is packing. Um the second reason
why it's hard is because uh this is not
a task that's easily automatable using a
classical stack. Uh because, you know,
errors can happen. The pouch itself is a
small deformable objects.
One of the thing that I really love
about this video is
yeah, um this is daytime, right? This is
when uh in the morning when the robot is
running. And if you scroll to the end of
the video, you can see that it's night
time. So, this is a robotic system that
performing a real task, packaging real
customer order in a real warehouse, and
it's running a full day workload.
And the majority of it are autonomous.
So, I I think this example was pretty
extraordinary to me because it didn't
even require that much data to get this
level of autonomy.
And so, the the takeaway here is
we want to figure out how do we
externalize the intelligence, the model
that we're building. And the one way to
do so is to work with company that want
to deploy robots today and scale the
deployment
and to work really closely with them. We
work as if we're on the same team. It's
very free flow of information to see if
the system that we built together with
this company are good enough for
deployment.
And one of the really critical aspect in
these deployment are the ability to make
mistake and to remotely intervene when
the system make a mistake so that the
system can recover.
And one of the key question is can you
get to a level of autonomy where you
don't need to remotely intervene as much
and you're essentially break even
from a financial perspective so that you
can scale deployment. And I think, you
know, for some of the task that we work
on with partner company, we are
essentially there.
So, with that,
let me end the presentation. I want to
leave some time for questions and answer
and discussion. I feel free to ask me
anything that's on your mind. And if you
want to learn more about us,
please go to our website, fi.website,
and take a look at our blog post. We put
a lot of effort into making them
presentable.
Thanks for listening.
>> [applause]
>> Hey, so Sergey said that you can get
quite far with like a gripper hand, but
since you're now incorporating data
from humans, is it maybe now time to get
like a more dexterous robot?
>> Yeah, so the problem with I think what
you're referring to multi-finger hand
is the following.
Um
it really depends on whether you want to
build hardware or you want to study
intelligence today.
Because if you want to study
intelligence today, then you would like
to have scale. Uh we believe that scale
is important for intelligence
behavior to emerge.
Um now, what do you need the scale? In
terms of hardware, you need hardware
that is cheap, that is reliable, and
that is easy to tally up.
And if you look at multi-finger hands,
you can get two out of three today and
not all three. Like you can get a hand
that is reliable and easy to tally up,
but it's not going to be cheap. Like you
know, for the price of one multi-finger
hand, you can get maybe six, seven
robotic system
uh with
uh two-finger gripper.
Um or you can get a multi-finger hand
that is cheap and easy to tally up, but
it's not going to be reliable. Like it
would break so often that
um you know, you would wonder why am I
doing this in the first place.
Um yeah, and so that's one argument why
um if you want to focus on the
intelligent question,
working using it, like studying that
using multi-finger hands um is a little
bit of a distraction today. Now, this is
not to say that multi-finger hand is not
important. Um I think it is, and you
know, when the hardware gets to the
point where
it satisfies those three criteria, then
we'll consider working on it.
And the other thing is we we probably
worked on like thousands and thousands
of tasks at Pi at this point, and
um we work on really realistic tasks.
And we haven't seen that many tasks
where you actually need something more
than, you know, a two-finger mechanism.
>> Uh okay. Uh first, nice presentation. I
just wanted to ask about the scaling of
this VLA models. Right now, I see that
in your paper you are getting some good
cross-embodiment generalization results,
and the hardware is reaching a point
where it's actually very cheap. So, what
is stopping you from building like big
data generation farms with thousands of
people
like collecting
multitask data, and then training the
model that you can just deploy in any
home. Do you have like very obvious
bottlenecks that you are trying to solve
at this point, or you think that we
reached this point actually?
>> Uh I see. Great question. So,
>> [clears throat]
>> let me tackle the last thing in your
question first, which is um deployment
of robot into the homes.
>> [clears throat]
>> Now, I want to build a home robot at
some point,
but I think it is incredibly hard to do,
and may not be the right thing to do
today.
Because I think
robots in the home
in the limit uh is kind of like uh
physical AI complete task. Like I think
if that works, then we would have solved
uh physical intelligence. Um
and so that's the
like science answer. There is also a
economics answer, where consumer
robotics is just really hard and selling
into the home in a way that
like creating a product that's
compelling, that is cheap, that is safe
um
it's just really hard. And because we
believe that robotics today are
bottlenecked by motor capability, we
want to focus on the research question
first.
Um right. So, why not the home today?
That's the first part. And then the
earlier part of your question, why not
collect lots of data and have data
collection farm?
Um we like we're scaling data
collections.
You know, there are many other company
in the world that are scaling up robot
data collection. Um the
critical question is really what do you
scale? Because there are many axes. For
example, do you collect data on many
different tasks and only a little bit of
data per task? Do you or do you collect
data on not so many tasks, but lots of
data per task? Uh what about human
video? Uh do you collect lots of it,
too? What about Yumi? Um what about the
robot embodiment? Do you collect data on
lots of robots or
and not as much data per robot or do you
collect data
with only a few robot platform with lots
of data per platform?
Um
How do you change out the objects? In
what environment do you collect the data
from?
Um like I don't think these questions
have an answer today and they really
need to be experimentally validated as
to what's useful.
Um and so you know, we want to be good
scientists and we'll study how to scale
by running experiments.
>> Hi. Thanks for the great presentation. I
wanted to ask um regarding the
difference between Pi 0.6 and 0.7.
So, for 0.6, in the paper, you talk a
lot about the problem with interventions
during training and like how much human
feedback you need. And you also very
clearly today highlighted like some of
the benefits of 0.7, you know,
outperforming some of the specializing
specialized tasks and all of that stuff.
But I wonder like
regard like with regards to training,
how much did you were you able to reduce
the interventions and how much more
efficient is it to train 0.7?
Like beyond the performance benefits you
showed.
>> Yeah. Are you referring to the
intervention during data collection or
evaluation?
>> Evaluation.
>> Yeah. Um
I don't remember the number off the top
of my head. Um the number should be in
the paper.
And
we generally measure uh throughput of
the overall systems.
Um there should be some intervention
number in there as well. Uh my um
kind of general summary of the result is
that there are just tasks that Pyro 7
can perform at a high-level performance
that Pyro 6 just can't do at all. Uh for
example, there's um
screwing a very tiny screw in the robot
arms.
Um yeah, Pyro 6 is
really can't do that task at all uh
unless you run specialist post training
uh for Pyro 6.
Um
and there was a figure that I shown
where the Pyro 7 model is actually
outperforming the Pyro 6 specialist,
especially in terms of throughput,
because the model is more robust to
environment change. And so it it it
generalizes better, like maybe the
lighting has changed or the object has
changed or the presentation itself has
changed.
Um so that's in terms of intervention
during evaluation. Now, you also
mentioned the question of training
efficiency.
Um
there's multiple ways to define training
efficiency.
Um one of the one that I think so lot
about is
um how much compute going through the
training run. Um
I would say between prior 06 and prior
07,
they're roughly comparable, actually. Um
which is great because you get a much
more performing model while not having
to increase the scale of your compute
significantly. I'm not sure that answer
your question exactly, happy to answer
follow up.
>> Yes, that was great.
>> Thanks a lot.
>> I have one more question.
>> Yeah,
thanks a lot for your presentation. Um I
just heard that P07 has a small word
model for action for
goal conditioning. And I think directly
I'm thinking about Dreamer Zero as a
full word action model. And so I'm I'm
guessing what are the uh
uh differences trade-offs. I [snorts] I
guess it's not black and white. So, are
you leaning on towards more word action
model maybe in the future or because of
inference costs, training costs, and
data collection, it's not needed? And
also, have you reached a fundamental
bottleneck with VLA's that would be
solved with word models? Or maybe you
think that fundamentally there's not a
difference
um between
uh the the the different models.
>> Yeah, that's a good question. I don't
think there is a
definitive answer to your question
today. Like I think all of the thing
that you asked is still open research
question.
We're exploring some of it, the
community exploring some of it. Um
I think
really what's crucial
um
when I think about this question is one,
uh model capability.
For example, you want long context
length. and you want a model that's
durable.
Um you want a model that
is high capacity enough to ingest really
large data set.
Um and I think VOAs or video model can
can can do both, but the way that you
train them might be quite different. Um
so one is yeah, model capability. Um
Number two is uh inference time
constraint um as you mentioned and
the reason why I mentioned inference
time constraint here is I actually think
it's a very solvable problems. Like if
we get to the point where you have a
really large model that is intelligent
enough to perform task at a very
high performance level and then, you
know, the only remaining um
obstacle is to make the model inference
faster. Like I think that's a very
solvable problems.
Um and so it'll be great if we get to
that point. Now,
we need to scale up the model. Uh right,
like currently the model at single digit
billions. I have no doubts this year um
we and the community will have
low double digit billions and then it's
going to go to, you know,
mid-range billion uh double digit
billion then it'll go to high-range
double digit billions. Um and so the
model size will continue to increase.
Um and I think we'll see much more
interesting emotional capability when
model size increase. Whether that's a
VOA or a video action model that will
scale better, like we need to try to
scale both up. Like I don't think I have
seen enough result in the community to
say that one is
like obviously the better choice
compared to the other.
>> Thanks. Do you have time for one last
question? One?
>> Yeah, go for it.
>> Hey, thanks for uh coming here and
giving the talk. Uh I was wondering if
you could elaborate on what you said
before on why you don't want to do a
home robot right now. Because in your
public demos sometimes like you do go to
homes and collect and data on homes and
show that you can do some like home
tasks to some reasonable success and I
think even generalize to new kitchens
sometimes.
So is it that you don't think if you get
a reasonable non-100% success rate on
home tasks that consumers won't buy it
or is it that you're concerned about
safety and that you would want to wait
until you have a really good model to
make sure it doesn't break things or
hurt people or why would you not focus
on home robots? Because in my mind I
would think that consumers would
tolerate like a 60% success rate in a
robot like loading a dishwasher and
folding your laundry because it's so
useful and it's fun and
there's no like economic output tied to
it as it would be in like commercial
settings.
>> Yeah, so I think the dream of home robot
is very real. Like I would like very
much to build a home robot at some point
too. Now there's a few things in your
question. The first things is
why I show a lot of demo on home tasks.
You know, why is that the case? Well,
when we release Pi Zero I think the
community thought of us as a laundry
company because so many
um of the tasks were laundry related
tasks. Now we pick home tasks for a very
specific reason um
is that it's a really good test bed for
research and communicating that
research. Um it's a good test bed for
research because the full complexity of
dealing with open-ended environments are
there. Um it's a good
a set of tasks for communicating the
research because one the tasks are very
relatable. Like you know, we know
robotics, but if um um
I were to show a very precise like
assembly task to the layperson in the
world, like they're not going to be able
to
really
grasp how interesting or how impressive
it is. Whereas if they see a laundry
folding robot, you know, they kind of
get a sense that it's hard and that this
would be useful to them eventually,
right? So, communicating or
communication of the progress to the
layperson, like you know, we we can look
at an assembly task and understand that
it's hard because we know robotics, but
that's not the case with the layperson.
Um
And regarding why not go for home robot
immediately right now, I I think the
model are not good enough. Um
like you know, you might be okay with a
60% success rate dishwasher robot, but
you know, someone else might not be. Or
you know, someone else might care a lot
more about um
human-robot interactions. Or someone
else might care a lot about oh, the
robot should not take up too much space
because um you know, they they don't
want it to get in their way. So, the um
I think diversity in human preference
uh is one of the reason why consumer
robotic is really hard.
Um and we think the bottleneck actually
to build a really good home robot
eventually is model capability, and we
will want to focus on that part of the
neck first.
Like I I don't think if you take the
model today and you try to build a home
robot with it, um you would be very
successful. I I think that
multiple scientific breakthroughs need
to happen for that to be true.
Now, the the the strategy that we've had
is very explicitly general purpose
robotics, right? Um
and you can think about how in language
model, you don't have to solve
language before the model are useful. Um
and so, we want to be at a position
where our surface area for success is
really large. And in some of the tasks
and some of the environment
model are good enough today for
deployment and we want to go after them
while still building up model capability
so that the surface areas for success is
larger and it's increasing and
eventually home robots will will be one
of the thing that the model are good
enough for.
>> Okay, thanks.
All right.
I think that's the end for Quan. Let's
thank him again, please
>> [applause]
>> for amazing talk.